victims of sexual assault protested in
the heart of the entertainment industry
hundreds of women marched yesterday
along the Hollywood Walk of Fame to send
a message against sexual assault and
harassment some wore t-shirts and
carried signs saying me to Massachusetts
prosecutors are looking into the conduct
of actor Kevin Spacey the Boston Globe
says they will meet with the son of a
former TV news anchor allegedly
assaulted by Spacey dareka Duncan is
here with how Hollywood is addressing
the growing concerns Tirico good morning
good morning Hollywood's annual award
season kicked into full swing over the
weekend and while the Academy Awards are
still nearly four months away the
reaction to allegations of inappropriate
conduct against Hollywood heavyweights
isn't showing any signs of slowing down
hundreds of people on Sunday brought
their fight against sexual violence to
the heart of Hollywood the March was
centered around the hashtag me to
movement bringing awareness to sexual
harassment tirana Burke founded it more
than a decade ago what we represent by
gathering and marching in the streets is
a reminder a living breathing reminder
that we are human beings not hashtags
the increasing number of allegations
against Hollywood power players is
drawing the attention of law enforcement
with the LA district attorney forming a
special task force to investigate the
claims of sexual assault
now the Boston Globe is reporting a
Massachusetts District Attorney is
looking into allegations Kevin Spacey
sexually assaulted an 18 year old man in
July of last year The Globe reports the
DA is interested in quote everything
that's relevant and material during
Saturday's governor's Awards the
unofficial start of Hollywood's award
season actors weighed in from the red
carpet this is the time to really look
at ourselves and go
is everyone in this room my brother and
sister it doesn't matter who you are as
a humanist this is something we need to
get rid of it's despicable and Aneesa
style Spacey's representatives have not
yet responded to our request for comment
but while the allegations continue to
pile up across Hollywood so far there
have been no criminal cases filed in Los
Angeles Charlie thanks to Rico